[Music]
are you ready yeah here we go
facebook or twitter facebook twitter
twitter pizza scotland or England
England Scotland Scotland England sorry
here were wine wine wine one phone call
or text funcles change text text
cheeseburger a hot dog
she's burgers cheeseburger what went to
the cinema day all night and we had to
my support dogs each so what's happening
cuddler kiss a booth at the same time oh
god oh see okay see ya
kiss coffee or tea coffee coffee coffee
tea city or country side
Jessie Oh countryside countryside oh
it's raising on country Scottish
countryside city I'm an out of both yes
you can have balls which will make the
exception of a uh horror or comedy
comedy comedy horror winter or summer
some winter I don't know I'm bit of a
this Mindy junkie oh you know nothing
about how cool it is okay but when it
snows I feel like that's a more
satisfying winter yeah if the snow
winter but yeah sunshine trainer plane
train train plane morning or evening
evening good evening evening toilet
paper over or under I don't sell my
question so like like at which way the
role goes oh I see guys I thought I was
thinking very much worst look um over
dog or cat dog dog potato Katrina
clap buzz yes party or movie Oh movie
movie quality friends or family clan
place sure
family friends Lee family family family
first underwear or commando Oh naked
underway mom do a sneeze
thank you guys so much and thank you
fans so much for watching and for all
the latest information be sure to follow
Outlander on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram cool
[Music]